Joseph's father is Jacob and Jacob is the patriarch of Israel,
essentially that the father of the 12 tribes.
And um,
we,
you might remember that,
uh,
he had a very morally
ambivalent halfway through life.
And it's one of the things that I think so interesting about the stories in the,
in the Old Testament is that
these so-called patriarchal figures are very realistic.
And it's something that I was also being struck by that accounts in the new
testament that way.
There's lots of things that Christ does that you'd think would have been edited
out over time and sanitize,
but they're not.
And the Old Testament is definitely not a book that's been sanitized.
And that's,
it's quite interesting that that's the case.
So you sort of see people with all their flaws and I've been trying to also
derive some general conclusions about
the moral of the story of the genesis stories and um,
because these stories are fundamentally moral and moral as far as I'm concerned,
it has to do with action,
right?
Because moral decisions are the decisions that you make when you're structuring
action.
When you decide to do one thing or another,
generally want to do things that are the best things that you can think of to do
and hence good.
But sometimes you also want to do things that are the worst things you can do.
You know,
because you're angry or resentful or bitter.
And so the moral decisions that you make that govern your actions are really the
most important decisions that you make in your life.
And it's not that easy to figure out how to make moral decisions.
We don't have an unerring
technology for that the same way as we do for say,
making decisions about empirical reality,
which in some ways seem a lot simpler.
Um,
partly because we can work collectively at it,
partly because we have a rigorous methodology for deciding what's true and
what's not.
So one of the things that's really struck me,
like it's an overarching theme,
I would say that emerges out of genesis,
especially after the really ancient stories,
uh,
say,
especially after the stories of Cain and Abel and Noah and
the Tower of Babel.
When you get to the accounts of the historically or historically real people,
one injunction seems to be get the hell out there and do something.
You know,
one,
one of the major themes for all of the Patriarchs that we've talked about,
Abraham say Jacob and Joseph is
move out into the world regardless of the circumstances at hand.
Now that's in,
in in the Old Testament stories that's basically portrayed as hearkening to the
voice of God.
Something like that.
Maybe you could think about that as destiny or a psychological calling.
Um,
and the funny thing too is,
is that it's not that these people have an easy time of it when they heed that
call.
So what's,
what's fascinating is that they often run into extreme difficulties right away.
And I think that's very interesting.
First of all,
because life is obviously full of extreme difficulties.
And second,
it's another example of the failure to sugarcoat things,
which is one of the things that I think makes a mockery of anti religious
theories that are even quite sophisticated,
say,
like Freud,
Freud thought of religion as a,
as a wish fulfillment essentially.
And,
and also marked who thought about religion as the opiate of the masses.
It's if those were true,
it seems to me that there'd be a lot more wish and a lot less reality,
a lot less stark,
harsh reality.
No,
I mean,
the first thing that Abraham encounters is a famine and then he has to hide his
wife and then he,
he basically journeys into a tyranny.
So that's about as bad as it gets in some ways.
And those themes re recur continually.
And no one ever lives where they're supposed to live.
They leave in live in Canaan and not the promised land.
And so it's a pretty rough,
it's a pretty rough series of stories.
But the fundamental idea is something like,
there's no time for sitting around.
There's time to go out into the world and engage.